der bayerische ministerpräsident markus
söder im streit darüber wer für die
union ins rennen zieht sogar am ende den
kürzeren gegen den cdu chef armin
laschet was hat das mit ihm gemacht
diese wochen wie ist dein blick auf die
cdu
und wann hat der lotter und in
deutschland endlich ein ende
[Musik]
ja und über diese fragen möchte ich
jetzt sprechen mit dem bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten und fast
kanzlerkandidaten markus söder gegen
abend nach nürnberg wieder schön gut
wir möchten beginnen mit einem blick auf
deutschland was an diesem wochenende in
unserem land los war
nach monatelangen lockt downs und einem
chaotischen im staat mit deutschland
jetzt endlich wieder auf wiedergewonnene
freiheit für geimpfte und genießen die
menschen strömen in das sommerwetter
lange schlangen wie hier vor sylt die
insel fährt an diesem wochenende den
tourismus wieder hoch
[Musik]
nächste woche ich bin schon zweimal
geimpft
ich freue mich riesig dass die bekehrten
aufmachen und ich in meinem lieblings
spielgarten wieder gehen kann
in zwei wochen werde ich mit meiner
zweiten moderner impfungen geimpft und
freue mich auch wieder auf den
biergarten endlich geht es wieder los
ein bisschen normalität wieder und man
kann seinen sport wieder so machen
jemand ich noch gedacht haben es ist
unser erstes steht heute und wir wollen
die sonne genießen und hoffen dass der
tag so schön schallt durch lustige
menschen sind würdig ist
dankbar sind dass er wieder raus kann
also schön wieder die schule lacht da
haben wir reichlich davon
und die genießen tag selber als obi
castro habe ich das gefühl dass corona
endlich vorbei also da sie hören die
menschen sind glücklich
haben sie auch das gefühl dass corona
jetzt vorbei ist
nein leider nicht aber es ist seine
zielgeraden nachdem wir sind ich gebe
aber zu einem lange zielgerade
wir haben nicht überall die gleichen
tendenzen wie auf sylt ist ein besonders
positiver fall die entwicklung aber
tatsächlich geht es über runter wenn es
runter geht es auch ganz
selbstverständlich dass ich dann auch
die lage besser besser nicht nur für die
inzidenz besser nicht in den
krankenhäusern sondern vor allem auch im
normalen alltagsleben
das heißt bei führungen machen ja nach
dem bundesgesetz einen sind dort wo man
unter 100 ist natürlich mit
hygienemaßnahmen natürlich mit
vorsichtsmaßnahmen und die zusätzlichen
freiheiten insbesondere wenn man zweimal
geimpft es entsprechend genau den
charakter das impfen die echte
langzeitstrategie ist wie geht es ihnen
ganz persönlich damit dass es jetzt
endlich nach vorne geht dass die zahlen
besser werden haben sie schon mal den
grill angeschmissen die nachbarn
eingeladen kommt bei ihnen auch
persönlich das alte leben zurück nein
für uns geht es ja gar nicht
erstens eine sehr hohe inzidenz hat so
dass das gar nicht möglich wäre aber zum
zweiten grün war für jeder selber also
grillen dasselbe rein das ist nicht das
problem
die sind noch nicht ganz über den berg
davon sich täuschen ja wir haben auch
noch immer wieder die herausforderung
dass wir hoffentlich nicht eine mögliche
indische mutation bekommen aber im
großen und ganzen würde ich es immer auf
einem sehr guten entwicklung und auf
einer besseren als noch gedacht ich
denke mal die dritte welle scheint unter
kontrolle zu sein aber ich bin von natur
aus eher etwas vorsichtiger denn wenn
man jetzt das dritte mal dass erlebt hat
mit jeweils einer welle die man besiegt
hat und dann doch wieder den sorgen mit
einer neuen ist man einfach ein bisschen
vorsichtig aber unterm strich würde ich
sagen trat durch das impfen ist einfach
mehr freiheit und möglichkeiten da wie
gesagt auf der zielgeraden
auch wenn es eine lange ist sie haben
die instanzen angesprochen wir wollen
uns einmal anschauen wie die inzidenz im
vergleich in deutschland aussehen
hier haben wir die grafik die sieben
tage ins ident bayern ist da ja
zumindest nicht im ganz positiven
bereich warum ist ausgerechnet bei ihnen
bayern das ja so als vorbild galt lange
zeit oder das sozusagen als modell
gepriesen wurde warum haben sie es noch
nicht geschafft
naja ich glaube wir legen schon ziemlich
gut sie dürfen nie vergessen wir waren
immer im zentrum der entwicklung und der
herausforderung
erstens weil wir die längste außengrenze
mit über 1000 kilometer wir sind bei der
ersten welle sehr stark getroffen worden
aus österreich heraus damals das
gestrüpp wir sind jetzt bei der dritten
welle sehr starke darf man
beispielsweise tschechien was ein
hochmodernes gebiet war man konnte das
richtig erkennen wie sich von osten her
ist die inzidenz erhöht haben und dafür
dass wir jetzt praktisch unter dem
bundesdurchschnitt oder gleich legen
dafür dass große flächenländer wie
warmes zahlen beiden württemberg doch
deutlich schlechter leben als wir sind
wir schon ehrlich so ganz zufrieden und
wir haben jetzt mittlerweile auch
bereits über 30 landkreise und
kreisfreie städte die unter den 110
einige sogar unter 50
als ich
die tendenz ist sehr positiv dass wir
sehr zufrieden aber wie gesagt es dauert
noch insbesondere den bereichen auch zu
thüringen hin
bei uns dieses coburg thüringen ist mit
abstand der spitzenreiter was die
höchstzahl der inzidenz im griff das
sind wir auch noch an den grenzbereichen
da müssen wir noch besser werden
wie lange dauert das jetzt noch also da
wir schauen immer noch neidisch nach
israel zum beispiel wo die clubs offen
sind wie lange wird dieser lockdown in
deutschland insgesamt noch dauern und
wann sie es bei uns auch so wie in
israel
na gut wir haben eine klare gesetzliche
regelung gilt zunächst mal bis 30 setzen
dass die notbremse wo über 100 ist geht
nichts was sozusagen unter 100 es gibt
es diese möglichkeiten die auch wir in
bayern jetzt ab morgen dann machen
außengastronomie kultur mehr sport also
all die bereiche die sie jetzt auch zu
recht in dem beitrag
vorhin erwähnt und angesprochen haben
und durch das impfen wird es jeden tag
besser
wir müssen schauen dass wir die impf
geschwindigkeit generell noch erhöhen
also impfen ist die einzige land
schreibt strategie und einstellen ist es
aber noch wie finde ich nutzen wir noch
nicht alle potenziale wir sollten
schneller in die diskussion gehen die
priorisierung abzuschaffen um die
geschwindigkeit zu erhöhen
wir sollten beispielsweise diese letzte
dose oder die letzte rest möglichkeit
aus der siebten oder 11 die sollten wir
nutzen das sollte der staat der bund
selbst von vornherein die garantie für
die ärzte übernehmen damit alles
verimpft wird an impfstoff was da ist
und wir sollten auch schauen in den
nächsten wochen dass wir noch einmal
versuchen eine geschwindigkeitserhöhung
dadurch zusammen indem wir in der frage
die wir impfen auch mehr präziser impfen
also ich glaube dass zb das strategische
impfen bei betrieben und familien ganz
wichtig ist wir haben in unseren
östlichen landesteilen als guter lebt
hat mir sehr hohe inzidenz da haben wir
gott sei dank durch den bund das war
sehr sehr gut mehr impfstoff bekommen
den haben wir nicht anfangen der
normalen priorität verimpft sondern sind
sehr bewusst vorangegangen um so die
fragen der mobilität neu zu bewerten
haben betriebe kämpft infektion nach
infektionsgeschehen und wenn sie heute
anschauen passt beispielsweise liegt
echt sensationell da oder schon leute
und das hat sich also bewährt also
intelligentes und auch freier das impfen
hilft aber wann sind wir über den berg
so dass er das was sie menschen sich
fragen wann endet endlich der im
november begonnenen lockdown und was
soll das
eigentlich noch mit den ausgangssperren
die ausgangssperre macht einen sind dort
wurde in stents im hoch ist ein
bewundert um an der stelle in die
sicherheit zu haben dass keiner
wirklichen macht die möglich sind weil
immer mehr statistiken die zeigen im
vergleich dort wo keine ausgangssperre
ist dass die instanzen genau so unter
gehen
nein bei uns hat sie gewirkt also ich
halte ich schon für ein wichtiges
instrument nicht so dass einzig wahren
sagen das ist nie die einzige sieht man
ein ganzes eine ganzes maßnahmenbündel
aber eine der maßnahmen die da sind ist
sicherlich die ausgangs beschränkung die
ausgangssperre
bei uns hat sie funktioniert deswegen
behalten wir die auch und zwar in der
konsequenten form in bayern wie wir sie
fordern da bleiben wir bei unserem kurs
den wir haben noch einige ecken wo die
cds doch noch sehr hoch ist da ist es
wichtig dass es dann nicht mehr
verbreitung gibt und ansonsten zu der
frage wann ist vorbei ist die genaue
prognose kann ihnen keiner geben aber es
wird jeden tag besser
sie sagen wir diesen tag besser der
lotter und gilt jetzt bis 30.06 ist es
danach vorbei ja bloß weil ein gesetz
ende des corona nicht vorbei immer das
ist ja unser grundproblem politische
entscheidungen sind das eine aber es war
haben wir in den letzten jahren gemerkt
haben darum es hängt von der
infektionsgeschehen ab von der vorsicht
der menschen ich glaube aber dass die
menschen in deutschland schon jetzt sehr
bewusst agieren und das impfen hilft uns
auch sehr und durch zwei mal hat man
einfach mehr mehr freiheiten ist sollten
übrigens auch scheinen dass die abstände
zwischen erste und zweite impfung
beispielsweise bei astra zenica das hat
man jetzt freigegeben
sie erinnern sich vielleicht wären
bayern gehen wird es manchmal kritisiert
gehen immer einen schritt schneller
voran als bei den hausärzten impfen
gemacht wir haben das gemacht jetzt
beispielsweise bei der frage welche
rechte kämpfen haben das wirkt dann auch
immer alle anderen vollziehen ist dann
gott sei dank war es dann immer gleich
alles gut und das sind glaube ich dass
wir das schon sehr gut vorankommen und
wenn wir jetzt noch gelänge
beispielsweise bei astrazeneca den
abstand zwischen acht und zwei impfungen
noch ein bisschen zu verkürzen erhöht
sich auch die wirksamkeit
des impfstoffs an maßnahmen eben noch
den ganzen sommer gehen sie davon aus
also die pandemie die pandemie
bekämpfung auf der gesetzlichen
grundlagen einer notbremse geht bis zum
30.06
und dann wird man sehen wie die
gesamtzahl ist hoch emotionales thema
herr söder schulen noch immer sind viele
schulen in deutschland geschlossen oder
die kinder können nur teilweise in den
unterricht gehen dazu hat sich die
ehemalige familienministerin kristina
schröder geäußert
der schaden wird immer noch täglich
größer wenn ich beispielsweise an die an
die kinder der mittelstufe denke die
sitzen in vielen bundesländern seit fünf
monaten zu hause und da reden wir über
zwölfjährige das sind keine erwachsenen
die man einfach vom computer packen kann
dann macht mich das ehrlich gesagt schon
fassungslos dass wir das in diesem land
einfach so zu lassen gerade weil andere
europäische länder das anders handhaben
und schon jetzt würde ich ein großes
fragezeichen daran machen ob wir
überhaupt jetzt im moment noch
schulschließung brauchen die absoluten
risikogruppen sind derzeit schon geimpft
kleine infektionsgeschehen das übrig
bleibt das muss unseres erachtens die
gesellschaft aushalten das sind wir den
kindern schuldig also da aus der politik
ist es immer die schulen werden als
letztes geschlossen und als erstes
geöffnet jetzt erleben wir dass ganz
viel geöffnet wird aber die schulen
weiter dicht bleiben warum
ganz so ist es nicht aber in der tat ist
es so dass es eben neue fahrern gibt am
anfang hat er gesagt auch wie die
kollegin gerade naja die schulen seien
gar nicht so schlimm gar nicht so
getroffen
das war ein schwerer irrtum wenn sie
anschauen dass die inzidenz
beispielsweise von den zehn- bis
19-jährigen in bayern jedenfalls wie
anderswo genauso deutlich über dem
durchschnitt liegt da hat sich das total
verändert bei den über 80-jährigen
deswegen erfolgt ist impfen ist es
generativ gesehen die gruppe die die
niedrigste inzidenz aufrecht also das
sieht man welches das impfen total hilft
und umgekehrt kann man sehen dass wir
einige bereiche wo wir aufpassen müssen
bei den unter zehnjährigen also das
heißt bei den grundschülern da glaube
ich sie die schäden durch distanz
unterricht weil er da nicht so
funktionieren kann
weil auch da und kultur technik geht die
es zu ende geht und weil die betreuung
auch durch die eltern eine ganz andere
ist als ob jemand 13 oder 14 ist da
macht es sinn deswegen haben wir da auch
ja auch bei uns und anderswo sind die
grundschulen deutlich stärker geöffnete
deutlich mehr möglichkeiten aber im
anderen bereich müssen allein und
stückweit vorsichtig sein
oder wird uns sehr stark der impfstoff
helfen den wir bekommen können
hoffentlich bald so dass dann auch in
dem bereich sicherheit herrscht aber sie
haben den schülern ja schon jetzt
wahnsinnig viel zugemutet den kindern
den eltern viele leiden darunter dass
sie nicht zur schule gehen können warum
ist man da nicht entschlossener jetzt
und sagt okay wir machen jetzt auch
wirklich die schulen durchgängig auf es
macht einfach keinen sinn zu sagen ich
mache jetzt mal einfach auch ohne
konzept und land sorgen terry war groß
in den schulen sie könnten regelmäßig
testen sie könnten täglich testen sie
könnten sagen wir machen abstands
konzepte in den schulen aber man hat so
ein bisschen das gefühl von diesem
versprechen dass die schulen als erstes
geöffnet werden ist nichts übrig
geblieben
aber das machen wir doch schon uns das
wissen sie doch es macht doch jeder
testen täglich wir haben entsprechende
abstände des testens ein wichtiges
instrument aber nicht das einzige was
haben sie in der schönen stadt tübingen
gesehen
die hat ja getestet wie die weltmeister
und trotzdem ist die inzidenz nach oben
explodiert das hat das ist ein
instrument aber nicht das entscheiden
wir testen ja abstände ja aber
insbesondere bei den weiterführenden
schulen war hilft schon der distanz und
dadurch sehr sehr gut aber es wird auch
da jeden tag besser
man kann es ja daran sehen wir haben
einfach uns auch die entsprechenden sie
denn zwingen wie auf bundesebene
wenn die incidents passt geht es über
den wechsel unterricht passt incidents
nicht bleibt es beim anderen nämlich
beim distanz unterricht hinzukommt
abschlussklassen sind der ausgenommen da
geht es jetzt um die abiturprüfungen
bald sind aber auch andere wichtige
prüfung gibt ja nicht nur abitur und
hinzu kommt noch dass wir uns alle
miteinander überlegen müssen wir
zusätzlich ein bildungs coaching machen
in einem fall gebe ich ihnen ganz ganz
sicher recht insbesondere bei den
bildungsferneren familien dort wo die
eltern ist unter lage sind selbst noch
ein zu springen oder mitzuhelfen oder
migrationsbereich da haben wir noch eine
menge aufzuholen und da muss auch durch
zusätzliches zusammen bildungs coaching
vieles nachholen muss die politik sich
entschuldigen dafür was den kindern zu
vermutet wurde den schülern zugemutet
wurde
ich weiß nicht ob entschuldigen richtige
weg ist sondern wir gehen ja alle
miteinander der herausforderung
schauen sie das ist doch von beginn an
der pandemie gibt es darüber
diskussionen es gab die eine diskussion
ist corona überhaupt gefährlich ich
glaube bis auf wenige glaube ich sehen
wir uns eigentlich dass diese gefahr
besteht dass unser land gespürt mit
tausenden von toten
die zweite frage ist welches instrument
ist das beste gab es unterschiedliche
philosophien ich glaube unterm strich
natürlich ist da ist eine abwägungsfrage
aber unter dem strich würde ich sagen
dass das was geschehen ist vertretbar
waren das auch vieles vieles richtig
wir haben dem land viele viele
möglichkeiten gegeben und wir haben
beispielsweise nigerias gehabt und wir
haben nie diese schwierigen situation
die ammerländer gab das wird glaube ich
ja ist das vertretbar besser machen kann
es immer bei der schule würde ich sagen
wenn sie mit dem satz an der stillen
einlagen bei der schule gab's auch
irrtümer viele haben gesagt die schule
kann gar nicht teil
das infektionsgeschehen sein das war
monatelang zwischen erster und zweiter
welle ein thema
man hat dann mehr gelandet ich glaube
jetzt ist man bei der schule von dem
viel viel besseren weg aber sie sprechen
da von den fw von den gefahren für die
schüler und gefahren dass die inzidenz
wieder hochgeht aber viele eltern sind
einfach wütend sind ratlos und wissen
nicht mehr so richtig was sie machen
sollen
können sie den wenigstens versprechen
dass ab nächstem schuljahr ist wieder
komplett normal wird und alle schulen
geöffnet sind also nächste mal öffnen
jeden tag schulen also schauen sie bei
dem bei dem trend der jetzt herrscht und
den wir gemeinsam auch begrüßen glaube
ich oder aber den sich alle freuen
öffnen ja jeden tag mehr schulen bzw
kommen immer mehr schulen wieder in den
wechsel unterricht das heißt der prozess
ist im gange
und wenn es jetzt so weitergeht bin ich
ganz feste überzeugung dass das jetzt
sehr gut geht und wenn uns dann gelingt
insbesondere nächsten schuljahr
es sind glaube ich jahres wird ein ganz
anderes schuljahr werden die neue infos
impfmöglichkeiten sagen wenn der
impfstoff der jetzt für die zwölfjährige
zugelassen
den müssen wir dann massenhaft schon vor
schulbeginn quasi in schulen fraktionen
mit geschlossenen gruppen impfungen
machen wenn uns das gelänge
davon bin ich aber fest überzeugt dass
das gelingt dann ist schule mit einem
ganz anderen sicherheits feeling mehr
möglich und dann braucht man ist diese
formen von schulschließungen sicher
nicht mehr
neben dem thema schulen wird häufig auch
diskutiert warum in nachbarländern schon
viel viel mehr offen ist als hier in
deutschland ich bin einmal zeigen wie es
in der schweiz aus sieht die inzidenz im
vergleich zu deutschland denn da stellt
sich heraus dass die inzidenz aktuell
genau auf dem selben level liegt wie in
ihrem freistaat und das also obwohl in
der schweiz sogar veranstaltungen
innenraum wieder erlaubt sind und
skiurlaub möglich war
sie haben das immer als unverantwortlich
kritisiert müssen sie heute nicht
zugeben ja andere länder haben es besser
gemacht
dort bin ich sagen kann ich kenne die
situation der schweiz nicht genau haben
sie sich einen besseren einblick
deswegen glaube ich mir da wenige urteil
andere zu kritisieren
mir ist nur aufgefallen dort wo
skifahren möglich war es dann aber sehr
schnell auch wieder schließen von pisten
gegeben weil es dort auch zur ansteckung
kam ganz überraschend weil jeder gesagt
hat da kann nichts passieren weil es
aber halt so war das an den im juli und
einen lift bereichen eben eine solche
infektion möglich war
das hat auch dann gegeben dass zum
beispiel bei der südafrikanischen
variante in tirol weißt du dass einzelne
skilehrerin ansteckungen ruhe gehabt
habe also ich würde da nicht sagen das
ist alles so viel besser gelaufen ist
aber die schweizer dazu schmidt haben
gar nicht wollen ja viel konsequenter
dies war die portugiesen man sehr viel
konsequenter
die spanier waren konsequente italiener
deswegen haben sie auch nicht über
zahlen unterm strich würde ich immer
sagen je konsequenter desto
erfolgreicher electric ab das jeweilige
corona konzept war desto problematischer
aber die schweiz seit mitte april
großzügige lockerungen geschlossen
trotzdem sinken die infektionszahlen wie
bei uns wie ist das denn möglich
ja woanders sind sie deswegen massiv
gestiegen also ich glaube da gibt es
keine regel wie gesagt ich kenne die
schweiz nicht ich kann von der von der
eu sprechen
da glaube ich lieber ganz gut sie haben
das thema impfen angesprochen
herr söder ist entwickelt sich jetzt
eine debatte auch in den vergangenen
tagen in den schaltern der
cdu-ministerpräsidenten da gab es eine
debatte um armin laschet der über die
freiheiten für geimpfte gesprochen hat
wie es in ihrem umfeld spüren sie da
dieses diesen viel diskutierten
angeblichen im flight der auch von
einigen politikern beschworen wurde
nein überhaupt nicht also ich meine
diese besagten schalte ich nicht da
beide sind kann ich dazu nicht sagen was
ich aber sagen kann deswegen habe ich
das auch für bayern vollzogen ist das
selbstverständlich
also grundrechte sind geborene rechte
und kein zug akkus oder luxusgut
und in dem moment wo die einschränkung
von einem grundrecht als ich wegfällt
weil nämlich der grund wegfällt nämlich
die verbreitung einer so schweren
krankheit wie corona an andere wenn das
wegfällt weil man geimpft ist dann kann
ich nicht mehr in gleicher weise agieren
und müssen grundrechte zurückgegeben
werden
deswegen war und bin ich für ein rasches
und zügiges zurückgeben von grundrechten
bzw 3 stellen dann von beschränkungen
weil es für mich ganz selbstverständlich
ist und ich denke auch dass die mehrzahl
will das einzige was dahinter steht und
das glaube ich ist immer die sorge von
dem ein oder anderen theatern die sage
und nicht einen sondern viele andere
seiner naja dann kommen ein bisschen
unter druck schneller zu impfen und
flexibler ch aber das haben wir doch
sowieso wir müssen noch alles dafür tun
ich habe es vorhin angesprochen dass die
ärzte mehr möglichkeiten die
betriebsärzte nicht im juni schon im mai
dran sind dass wir mehr möglichkeiten
haben gezielt in zu können dass wir die
mehr dosen nutzen können und uns so ein
zufall ist es wirklich endlos lange an
möglichkeiten wir schneller geht und wir
sind was mich mal so ein bisschen
beschwerde ist dass ich diese vorschläge
mache was ball kommt erst nein schwierig
muss doch nicht sein und fünf oder zehn
tage später wird es dann genauso gemacht
also
wir könnten noch ein bisschen weiter
sein wenn wir alle die gleiche
geschwindigkeit philosophie hätten
nämlich so schnell und so viel wie
möglich zu finden wenn sie über die
grundrechte sprechen was könnte da jetzt
passieren in den nächsten tagen den
nächsten wochen was kann man beschließen
damit dass dann auch wirklich
funktioniert und damit es vorangeht und
dass diejenigen die eben geimpft sind
wirklich alles wieder machen können na
ja also das ist ja jetzt beschlossen das
gilt ja bei uns in bayern galt es
bereits ab donnerstag jetzt eher in ganz
deutschland ist es jetzt vollzogen
worden
jetzt muss man sehen wie sie es aus
wirkt im moment sind sie ja noch nicht
so viel in die zweifach denn es geht ja
mit zweifach impfung
die erstimpfung reicht leider noch nicht
aus aber trotzdem hilft diese zweite
impfung schon eine menge übrigens die
erste impfung hilft die inzidenz
herunterzufahren
weil nämlich weniger leute sich damit
letzte infizieren und weil hier mit der
erstimpfung schon guten schutz hass und
deswegen mit beiden zusammen wird es
jetzt sehr schnell neue möglichkeiten
geben deswegen bin ich relativ wird
sollte zum beispiel das in zwei wochen
zumindest in dem bereich wo die inzidenz
unter 100 es pfingsten laub mit test und
allen entsprechenden konzepten auch
möglich sein
aber wo wir schon wieder gescheitert
sind ist das thema passt jetzt heißt es
dass diejenigen die geimpft sind darauf
warten müssen hat die digitale version
erstellt sind und dann wieder mit ihrem
gelben passt zum arzt laufen müssen um
das ja in die technik einzutragen wie
kann das sein dass wir auch bei dem
thema schon wieder so versagt haben ich
möchte etwas sagen sich die geworden ist
aber da schreiben sie mal ihren sparen
wir dazu ich verstehe es ehrlich gesagt
auch nicht weil weil unter uns gesagt so
schwer ist das nicht jedes mal wenn es
um digitale optionen geht brauchen wir
länger obwohl wir doch ein super technik
land sind wir haben dieses dieses modell
das für den digitalen impfausweis gehen
soll ist ja schon einmal erprobt ist
sogar aus bayern in altötting
das ist für ganz deutschland aus zu
holen dürfte eigentlich nicht so schwer
sein
es wird schon sicher kommen aber wie
immer halt also bei uns kommt der zug
halt mehr zehn minuten zu spät
es ist leider in bei digitalen fragen
ist es leider so
aber irgendwann kommen sie dann doch
aber ich gebe ihn zu mir wäre lieber es
ging schneller aber die kombination mit
dem bundesgesundheitsminister die
arbeiten auch mit hochdruck punks kein
vorwurf nur feststellen
digital ein großes zukunftsthema was
auch die union im wahlkampf in dem
zentrum gestellt hat bei dem thema cdu
viele fragen sich wie sehr sie sich
eigentlich immer noch ärgern dass sie es
nicht geworden sind der kanzlerkandidat
gar nicht das glaube ich nicht
da ist aber so
die entscheidung gefällt worden und das
ist okay die frage ist jetzt wie wir
damit umgehen und über das beste daraus
machen
es hatte nicht noch nicht einen totalen
hype ausgelöst sie waren ja damals so
weit ich mich erinnern kann
großer anhänger der idee für armin
laschet soweit ich das jedenfalls
gelesen habe und haben auch damals
gedacht wie viele an braucht die halt
eine andere auffassung es könnte einen
richtigen hype auslösen
soweit sie immer noch nicht aller
stimmen sich jetzt noch ich habe nie
weil die schweizer sondern ich habe
gesagt dass sozusagen in ihrer politik
auch durchaus eine gefahr bestehen
könnte für den wahlkampf das war die
argumentation ich habe nicht über ein
hype gesprochen und dann laschet
aber vielleicht genau zu dem thema
generalsekretär hat gesagt
entschuldigung ich dachte es gelesen zu
haben ich dachte was gelesen waren da
ganz euphorisch aber das ist ja auch
zulässig tschuldigung es ist ja zulässig
jeder hat ja seine position und jeder
seine beweggründe und es gibt gute
argumente für jeden und es gab am ende
sicher auch gute argumente im
cdu-vorstand für armin laschet und
deswegen respektiere das habe ich von
anfang gesagt und jetzt muss man halt
schauen dass wir in armin laschet ist
allein aus hessen ist als armin laschet
alleine schuld daran dass die
umfragewerte so schlecht sind also
nächste mal ist es in zeiten in denen
wir leben sind personen spielt die
zentrale aber nicht ist doch ganz
selbstverständlich das kann man immer
mehr personen spielen die zentrale rolle
denn die programme der parteien sind
nicht ganz so jedenfalls viele nicht
unterscheidbar für viele menschen sind
optionen grundvertrauen angela merkel
hat es hier mal sehr gut bewiesen aber
ja
ganz lange zeit hinweg erfolgreich zu
sein und bei jeder bundestagswahl lag
sie dann auch persönlich deutlich vorher
jeweilige mitbewerber also kommt es
darauf an dass man da erfolgreich ist
und natürlich ist da eine andere
enttäuscht gewesen war der wahl auch mit
der auswahl des kandidaten
möglicherweise aber das zählt jetzt
alles nichts das heißt nach vorne zu
schauen und davidson kandidaten der
union nämlich an mit lasso zu
unterstützen sie sagen nach vorne
schauen aber gleichzeitig kommen ja aus
münchen immer wieder sticheleien zum
beispiel hat der generalsekretär gesagt
zitat die große enttäuschung über den
ausgang der personalentscheidung also
die kanzlerkandidatur spielt sich in den
umfragen wieder viele nicht nur in
bayern hätten sich markus söder
gewünscht armin laschet ist nun
verantwortlich die umfragen zu drehen
würden sie das so unterschreiben ist er
also allein schuld das ist wieder zwei
verschiedene dinge des 1
markus blume geschrieben hat natürlich
gab es enttäuschend war ja ganz
besonders aber anderswo ja auch aber das
jetzt glaube ich mittlerweile schon
überwunden weil man ja immer nach vorne
blickt und weil mir die alternativen
sieht also olaf scholz überzeugt nicht
und bei den grünen sind auch viele
fragezeichen jetzt dahinter was den
wahlkampf betrifft das wahlprogramm wie
sieht die grüne warb aufstellen wollen
man sieht er als heute sie schmeißen ja
sogar persönlichkeiten aus ihren reihen
hat die lange gelobten sind die
eigentlich eine sehr erfolgreiche
kommunalpolitik anschreiben machen hat
mir das nichts aus weil er eben eine
andere meinung sie boris palmer auch
ausgeworfen
ich kann da nicht jemand raus werfen der
bei der csu ist aber wenn etwas
ähnliches in ihrer partei passiert wäre
mit einem oberbürgermeister kann ich
meine csu so was gar nicht vorstellen
dass es solche streik debatten gibt
wir haben uns immer alle so lieb und
sind so konstruktiv miteinander des
kannibalen im märz so nicht vorstellen
liegt aber auch daran wir haben dadurch
ohnehin leidenschaft in der diskussion
also kann ich forscher aber unabhängig
davon
ich glaube einfach es ist jetzt eine
spannende zeit man muss auch
programmatisch nachlegen wir haben bei
der auswahl achten vertrieben wir
beschließen als ein mann heraus wurde
übertrieben und ihrer sicht wenn sie
sich anschauen was da passiert ist bei
boris palmer war der rauswurf
übertrieben oder können sie das schon
verstehen oder der versuch des rauswurfs
über die mitgliedschaft nicht verstehen
wie man die mitgliedschaft in einer
partei entscheiden natürlich nur
diejenigen der partei dafür fehlt
manchmal des vielen wie man sich in der
grünen partei benimmt und darüber denkt
man muss unterscheiden zwischen harten
äußerungen im einzelfall die dann als
sehr kritisch zu bewerten sind dafür
habe ich verständnis und umgekehrt habe
ich aber den eindruck dass das es seit
längerer zeit eine entfremdungsprozess
zwischen palma und den grünen gibt es
ist ja spürbar gewesen
das war wahrscheinlich jetzt das letzte
der letzte tropfen der das fass zum
überlaufen gebracht
aber letztlich entscheiden ist die
grünen alleine ist zeigt aber nur dass
von dieser heilen welt in den von den
grünen gern uns alle vermitteln wollen
dass das nicht so stimmt das ja zum
beispiel total auffällig dass der arme
anton hofreiter nahezu versteckt wird
denn jedes interview von anderen hof
weiter bedeutet in der regel ein halbes
prozent mehr für die union
deswegen würde ich auch mitwirken gibt's
anton hofreiter noch gibt es die
fraktion auch alle da gibt es da so
einen sohn so ein ganz bestimmtes modell
wenn die grünen das jetzt machen weil
sie es ja auch so spannend ja ich finde
viele ideen gut weil wir ja auch kamera
man kann auch grüne politik ohne grünen
machen den in wahrheit machen die grünen
in den bundesländern
genau das gleiche oder noch schlimmer
als alles fällen bäume
sie bauen straßen sie fahren diesel also
so eine große moral wie die grünen gerne
vorhaben haben sie nicht das einzige was
sie haben es mal eine doppelte es gab da
in dieser woche ein foto von ihnen auf
twitter dass viel diskutiert wurde sie
auf einer bank sitzend in der natur und
viele haben sich da an robert habeck
erinnert was wollen sie uns sagen mit
dem foto ist ja mit dem foto wollte ich
sagen dass ich auf der bank sitze und
ich war direkt hat einen der grössten
moore in süddeutschland dass wir für 200
millionen euro zu erhalten um die co2
speicherung voranzubringen ist ja auch
etwas faszinierendes wir reden bei dem
co2 thema reden die meisten ja nur von
höheren preisen
ganz fasziniert dass er die grünen
überschlagen sich geradezu mit immer
höheren belastungen für die bürger es
gibt aber auch andere wege klimaschutz
daheim im land vor ort zu machen
mit dem er nicht nur die wälder
aufforstet zum beispiel auch mode weil
die infra co2 speicher sind zu machen so
das foto war ihm dann anlässlich dieser
situation gemacht und ich fand es
eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht aus
sie sprechen das umweltthema an was auch
im wahlkampf natürlich ein großes thema
klima thema sein wird wenn wir uns jetzt
die nächsten tage nächsten wochen
anschauen und die umfragen für armin
laschet nicht weiter nach oben gehen
oder so bleiben wie sie jetzt sind
können sie sich vorstellen das ist dann
eine debatte in der union gibt ob man
kurz vor der wahl den kandidaten
austauschen muss nein nein
das halte ich für völlig absurd ich habe
mich gewundert dass daniel güter so eine
debatte begonnen hat normal dass es dann
nicht wir den ball sehr treffsicher mit
seinen einschätzungen auch flexibel aber
der stelle hat mich das alexa gewundert
nein für mich ist völlig klar laschet
ist nominiert und armin laschet ist der
kanzler kann aber eindeutig steht auch
dahinter und zwar zu 100 prozent aber
gilt denn ihr angebot noch an die cdu
also nehmen wir an armin laschet oder
andere in der partei würde auf die idee
kommen und sagen das wird nichts und wir
rufen jetzt mal in münchen an und fragen
markus söder
ob es doch machen will wenn sie dann
bereit
ich glaube nicht mehr dass ein solcher
situation eintritt
armin laschet ist nominiert armin
laschet will und armin laschet wird aber
wären sie bereit gilt wird die angebot
noch an die cdu dass sie als kanzler
kandidat bereitstehen
mein angebot stetig werde aber mit
laschet unterstützen aber was wäre für
den fall so das jetzt einfach mal
nachgedacht armin laschet kommt selbst
zu der erkenntnis dass es knapp werden
könnte gegen frau bernburg und hat angst
die wahl zu verlieren und würde sie
anrufen und würde fragen mensch
vielleicht tauschen wir doch wenn sie
dann bereit
glauben sie ernsthaft dass armin das tun
würde
und glauben sie ernsthaft dass ich mir
jetzt auch so eine spekulation einlassen
würde
und glauben sie noch ernsthafter dass
ich das jetzt sagen würde
ganz im gegenteil ich glaube also
unterschiedlich große stehvermögen der
will jetzt auch und er hat es aber
erklärt dass auf jeden fall in berlin
bleibt er hat sich aus entschieden
düsseldorf in jedem fall den rücken zu
kehren oder achten dass immer wenn man
single und ich finde es auch eine
konsequente entscheidung und wie gesagt
er hat unsere unterstützung war es uns
ankommen dass cs und natürlich wir
wollen uns einbringen
wir haben unsere ideen und wir dürfen
die auch einbringen weil wir im
zweifelsfall immer einen
überdurchschnittlichen beitrag bringen
zum unions erfolgt ohne die bayern ohne
die csu kann kaum jemand in der union
erfolgreich sein und deswegen tun wird
ist aber natürlich voller demut und und
mit harmonie friedrich merz hat gesagt
sie müssen über 40 holen in bayern damit
was werden kann
mit armin laschet als kanzler schaffen
sie das
ich bin total dankbar dass friedrich
merz uns an der stelle hilfestellung
gibt seine erfahrungen insbesonders den
90er jahren die er damals als aktiver
politiker
die helfen uns sicher und er ist ja
jemand der am tegernsee wohnt und es
wird schon ein alter bayer quasi ist und
insofern freuen wir uns über jede hilfe
sie sagen dir fakten aus den neunziger
jahren heißt das dass friedrich merz für
sich jetzt nicht so wirklich moderne
politik ausstand waren aber seine aktive
politische zeit war er im kern ende der
90er anfang des jahrhunderts gewesen
wir haben natürlich eine sehr
überragende kompetenz wenn es um
kapitalmärkte wenn es um aktien geht und
ähnliches mehr hedgefonds da hat er sich
in den letzten jahren deutlich als
wirtschaftsexperte einen ganz großen
namen gemacht deswegen ist es auch
folgerichtig dass armin laschet ihm die
option dann gibt sich um das thema
finanzen im in der cdu mit zu kümmern
insofern ist der rat immer willkommen
ich bin da nicht so wie ich bin ja nicht
immer so so so kleinteilig wie manch
einer der partner jedem wort hinter dem
komma hinter jeder in der produktion
dann immer gleich ein angriff setzt wir
müssen andere union uns schon alle so
ein bisschen ins auch wenn wir das
gewinnen wollen
auch die notwendige untereinander kraft
und freiheit zugestehen dass optimal wie
möglich zu machen und da kann jeder
seinen beitrag bringen
die union ist eine große familie mit
unterschiedlichen persönlichkeiten mit
unterschiedlichen temperamenten und das
beste was wir tun können ist einander zu
unterstützen und desto müder und ich
freue mich deswegen umgekehrt wenn ihr
dann beitrag bringen will die csu zu
unterstützen das tun ja im übrigen
tausende von leuten die jetzt bei uns
eingetreten sind als online mitglieder
aus ganz deutschland wie viel prozent
muss armin laschet holen damit es klappt
wie viel muss die cdu und die union
insgesamt machen so viel wie möglich was
halten sie für realistisch lässt sich im
moment noch nicht abschätzen also ich
hätte
ehrlicherweise nicht gedacht dass wir
jetzt in den umfragen das ist so ist
dass die grünen so stark vor uns liegen
deswegen wird es schon ein harter
wahlkampf weil es ist er in der regel so
dass innerhalb eines wahlkampfes gar
nicht so viel neue themen kommen
es wird schon ein hartes kopf an kopf
rennen und man darf nicht vergessen es
wird auch eine recht schwierige
herausforderungen
es gibt auch andere strategische
optionen im moment jedenfalls wird zwar
schwarz-gelb eng so dass dann die gefahr
besteht dass möglicherweise ist sogar
eine ampel geben kann was ich mir für
die union echt nicht vorstellen kann ist
grün schwarz und sie sehen ja die
herausforderung die man jetzt hat zu
recht wir müssen die grünen auch
attackieren und stellen in den
führungsanspruch und gleichzeitig in
baden württemberg eine koalition machen
insofern gibt es da noch eine menge
argumentation herausforderung des
darzustellen und da müssen wir uns
nächsten wochen echt einfach anstrengend
aber wieviel stark bewerten wie
anna-lena werburg die umfrage königin
wie gut ist die tatsächlich was mir
auffällt sie hat sich sehr genau auf
diese aufgabe vorbereitet
vielleicht hat es auch robert habeck
unterschätzt ich weiß es nicht
wenn ich übrigens auch kenne und auch
jenseits parteipolitischer konkurrenz
war danach sehr unterschiedliche
auffassungen
doch sehr respektiere setzte sich sehr
darauf vorbereitet auf diese kandidatur
und bislang ist auch kann man kann man
sagen eine sehr sehr kein interview
völlig misslungen
aber eines muss man schon sagen und das
glaube ich schon der rolle ist sie also
ich glaube nicht dass man nun mit
erfahrung argumentieren kann also man
kann jetzt sagen mensch ich habe schon
100 jahre politik gemacht deswegen bin
ich geeignet aber wenn man noch nie im
leben weder als staatssekretär noch als
minister die verantwortung hatte in
einer regierung einfach das prozessuale
kennt dann ist es gar nicht so leicht
wenn man dann von einem auf den anderen
tag chef sein wir wissen sie wenn jemand
anfängt als als bei einer zeitung als
redakteur ist zumindest überraschend
wenn er dann gleich am nächsten nach
chefredakteur wird oder wenn jemand den
führerschein macht demnächst nach gleich
die formel 1 wird da habe ich so ein
bisschen sage das ist dann eine
regierung war von vielen guten ideen
werden könnte aber in der praxis von
unzähligen problemen und beides braucht
es braucht handwerkliche solidität
aber es braucht doch politische
inspiration und ich finde dass die kombi
bei uns beiden besser sich wiederfindet
jemand der über sich selbst sagt dass er
viel regierungserfahrung hat es olaf
scholz und die spd hat heute ihr
wahlprogramm verabschiedet olaf scholz
seine kandidaten rede dort gehalten
was glauben sie wie groß ist seine
chance bundeskanzler zu werden nicht so
hoch
das heißt ja ich glaube nicht dass olaf
scholz bundeskanzlerin über über fünf
prozent schaffte aber schon oder
die spd wird natürlich über zehn prozent
kommen
wie hoch bei sich nicht entscheiden am
ende die wähler aber mein gefühl ist
dass dass es eher ein wettbewerb
zwischen schwarz und grün ist um den
platz eins und das die spd gar nicht so
eingreifen kann
was auch einfach daran liegt man kann
schlecht jahre lang in der regierung
alles mit beschließen sich sogar als
tragende säule der regierung zu
definieren zu wollen und dann zu sagen
es war alles ganz anders also dass das
funktionieren wird und insofern glaube
ich ist ein mittlerer
glaubwürdigkeitsproblem dar und ist ein
ganz seriöser mann gibt es nix aber so
beim thema inspiration und charisma
glaube ich ist ist die luft nach oben
auch noch ist noch ein bisschen luft
nach oben also kann sein und deswegen
glaube ich dass das am ende zwischen
armin laschet und annalena baerbock da
das ist schon da da ist einfach mehr
musik drin und aber es wird trotzdem
einen zugang mystery elia geben
vielleicht auch bei euch weiß es nicht
wo die drei antreten werden und dann
schauen wir mal was ich am besten
schlägt ich setze auch trafen zum
abschluss herr söder könnten sie sich
denn persönlich vorstellen nach berlin
zu wechseln eine super minister im
kabinett von asche zu werden nein der
post ist auch durch friedrich merz
besetzt herzlichen dank markus söder für
das gespräch und noch einen schönen
abend in nürnberg alles gute
ja das war unser interview mit markus
söder dem bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten und fast
kanzlerkandidaten über corona und was
bei der cdu passiert
[Musik]